سالنا الناس ما رايك في نشر خصوصيات
الفنانين عبر مواقع التواصل نتابع
الاجابات
[موسيقى]
شخص اللي يصور خصوصيات المشاهير او
خصوصيات الممثلين فهمت عباره عن انه يريد
انه يحطم المشهور يعني المشهور ناجح مبدع
في مجاله
فيحاول انه يحطمه فيحاول يصيد اخطائه يقوم
يتصور يطفي لانه ممكن ان هذا المشهور واثق
بالشخص هذا وكانوا مع بعض هذا نجح وهذا لا
للاسف اصبحت ظاهره سيئه جدا الحقيقه
الفنان انسان
بطبعه والله انا اشوفها صراحه النفس واول
زمان يعني كانت حنا عندنا الخصوصيه اساس
اساس كل شيء الحرفيه والله اني اشوف
الخصوصيه بصراحه لها حدود مو اي خصوصيه
تطرح العالم يعني السوشيال ميديا لازم
يكون في لها حدود صراحه
فصالات مشاكل
[موسيقى]